Glen's not being mean when he mentions his other family, the one back in Africa. He's only seven, and adopted, and black, living with Cate and her husband, who are white.
格伦提到他在非洲的另一个家庭时并不是恶意的。他才七岁，是个被收养的黑人男孩，和凯特及其丈夫住在一起，他们是白人。
It comes up if he's punished, for instance. The best example I can think of is he's not allowed to cross the street by himself at seven. And he went over to a neighbor's house and then he came back by himself. And I kind of saw him do that. I knew he was looking, but I followed through. This is against the rules. And so when he came in the house he was sent to his room. And it's upstairs. And he sort of stomped up the stairs. "I'm going to leave. I'm out of here. I'm out of here. I'm going back to my family in Africa. I'm out of this family." Because in Africa, he was a prince, you have to understand.
比如他受罚的时候，这件事就会被提起。我能想到的最好的例子是，他七岁时还不被允许独自过马路。他跑到邻居家，又独自回来了。我其实看见他这么做了。我知道他在观察我，但我还是照章办事。这是违反规定的。所以他进屋后被关进了自己的房间。房间在楼上。他跺着脚上了楼。“我要离开。我受够了。我走人了。我要回非洲找我的家人。我要离开这个家庭。”因为你必须明白，在非洲，他曾经是个王子。
And he's stomping up the stairs and I sort of said to him, "They have rules in Africa."
他跺着脚上楼时，我对他说：“非洲也有规矩。”
And he said, "Yeah, but they don't have roads in Africa. And so I wouldn't be grounded in Africa."
他说：“是啊，但非洲没有公路。所以我在非洲才不会被禁足呢。”
Now this departs from reality in a number of ways. Number one, of course, there are roads in Africa. Number two, Glen wasn't adopted from Africa. He's not a prince. He was adopted from Chicago, which he knows very well. He has other parents who he could fantasize about, other parents who he could actually meet. But he doesn't want that.
现在，这在很多方面都脱离了现实。第一，当然，非洲是有公路的。第二，格伦并不是从非洲收养的。他也不是什么王子。他是从芝加哥收养的，这一点他很清楚。他有其他的父母可以幻想，其他的父母他实际上是可以去见的。但他不想那样。
Not yet. I ask that many times and I have offered to help him find them. He's not ready for that.
还没到时候。我问过他很多次，也主动提出帮他寻找他们。但他还没准备好。
It's so interesting that it's not a desire for the actual parents, it's a desire for perfect parents.
很有趣的是，这并不是对亲生父母的渴望，而是对完美父母的渴望。
Fantasy is pretty wonderful. If you were a prince in Africa you wouldn't want to give it up either.
幻想是件非常美妙的事情。如果你在非洲是个王子，你也不会想放弃这一切的。
In 1908, Sigmund Freud wrote an article with the disturbing name "Family Romances," in which he pointed out how common it is for children to fantasize, at some point or another, that the parents that they live with are not their real parents. Their real parents are out there, somewhere, and are perfect. Aristocrats, Freud says. It's comforting compared with the flaws of any real parents. And if you are somebody whose real parents aren't around anymore, really, how will you choose to imagine them? When do you want reality and when do you want fantasy?
1908年，西格蒙德·弗洛伊德写了一篇标题令人不安的文章，叫《家庭罗曼史》，他在文中指出，孩子在某个时刻幻想自己现在的父母并非亲生父母是非常普遍的现象。他们的亲生父母在某个地方，而且是完美的。弗洛伊德说，是贵族。与任何现实父母的缺点相比，这令人感到安慰。如果你是一个亲生父母已不在身边的人，你真的会选择如何去想象他们呢？你什么时候想要现实，什么时候又想要幻想？
Well, today on our radio show, we bring you stories of children put into that position. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, stories from the Missing Parents Bureau. We bring you four case examples.
今天，在我们的广播节目中，我们为您带来处于这种境地的孩子们的故事。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的故事来自“失踪父母调查局”。我们为您带来四个案例。
Case One, Better Left to the Imagination. Why mothers who are impregnated with samples from sperm banks might choose to know less about the donors rather than more. Case Two, Tell It to the Void, in which we have these funny, moving letters the mom of a 13 year old has written to the kid's absent dad, letters she writes even though she has no idea where to send them. Act Three, I'm an Orphan; Don't Tell My Mom. Starlee Kine remembers back in the day when everybody wanted to be an orphan. Act Four, Runaway Mom. It's the old story. Baby meets mom. Baby loses mom. Baby asks after mom. Adoptive parents wonder what to say about mom. That story from Dan Savage. Stay with us.
案例一，留给想象更好。为什么通过精子库受孕的母亲们可能选择少了解捐赠者而不是多了解。案例二，告诉虚空，我们收录了一位13岁孩子的母亲写给她缺席父亲的感人信件，尽管她根本不知道寄到哪里。第三幕，我是孤儿，别告诉妈妈。斯塔莉·凯恩回忆起每个人都想成为孤儿的旧时光。第四幕，逃跑的妈妈。这是个老生常谈的故事。宝宝遇见妈妈。宝宝失去妈妈。宝宝询问妈妈。养父母在想关于妈妈该说些什么。这是丹·萨维奇带来的故事。请继续收听。
Act One, Better Left to the Imagination.
第一幕，留给想象更好。
If you want to understand how much kids and the parents left behind think about an absent parent, and what is that they do think about, consider what happens when kids are born to infertile couples, or to single moms, with sperm gotten from a sperm bank. Most sperm banks provide all sorts of information about their donors. And parents getting this sperm can actually choose how much they want to find out. How much they want their kid to find out. And how much they'd rather not know. Alix Spiegel has our story.
如果你想了解孩子们和被留下的父母对缺席的亲人有多么在意，以及他们到底在想什么，可以看看不孕不育夫妇或单身母亲使用精子库的精子生下孩子时会发生什么。大多数精子库提供各种关于捐赠者的信息。而购买精子的父母实际上可以选择他们想要了解多少。他们希望孩子了解多少。以及他们宁愿不知道多少。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔带来了我们的故事。
The donor is German. His interests include music, literature, and comparative religion. He claims to have scored 780 on his math SATs and says that as a child he excelled at both violin and piano. That in fact, in school he was at the top of his class in music theory. He lists his favorite qualities as discipline, strength, honesty, and order. And when asked what message he would like to convey to the recipients of his semen he writes, "Take the middle path. Avoid extremes. Treat everyone you meet the way that you would like to be treated. And please, read The Razor's Edge by Somerset Maugham."
捐赠者是德国人。他的兴趣包括音乐、文学和比较宗教学。他声称他的数学SAT考了780分，并说小时候他在小提琴和钢琴方面都很出色。事实上，他在学校的音乐理论课上名列前茅。他列出自己最喜欢的品质是纪律、力量、诚实和秩序。当被问及想给精子接收者传达什么信息时，他写道：“走中间道路。避免极端。像对待自己一样对待你遇到的每一个人。请阅读萨默塞特·毛姆的《刀锋》。
The donor is Chinese. He says that he is excellent at visualizing abstracts and can, quote, "Take any car apart and learn it inside out." He can run six miles. He can play guitar. His hobbies include microbrews and football. When asked about his ambitions in life he writes that he wants to "help transform the moon for human habitation and create some kind of food supply that will replace meat." He says he's become a sperm donor because he wants to make sure that his genes are perpetuated into the future. He also writes that he's poor. A student. He says he needs the money.
捐赠者是华人。他说他擅长抽象视觉化，并引用说：“可以拆解任何汽车并彻底弄懂它。”他能跑六英里。他会弹吉他。他的爱好包括精酿啤酒和足球。当被问及人生的雄心壮志时，他写道他想“帮助改造月球以供人类居住，并创造出一种能替代肉类的食物来源。”他说他成为精子捐赠者是因为他想确保自己的基因能够延续到未来。他还写道他很穷。是个学生。他说他需要这笔钱。
There are six-foot philosophers and pot-smoking surfers, future doctors, out-of-work computer programmers, and hopeful actors who are currently employed at the Dairy Queen. They come in all shapes and sizes, but most of them are there for the money. Young men who walk off the street and are given dirty magazines, a small plastic container, and a private room.
这里有六英尺高的哲学家、抽大麻的冲浪者、未来的医生、失业的程序员，还有在冰雪皇后工作的怀揣梦想的演员。他们来自各行各业，高矮胖瘦各不相同，但他们大多数人都是为了钱。这些年轻人走在大街上，被塞给成人杂志、一个小塑料容器和一个私人房间。
But first there are forms to fill out-- health surveys, family histories, essay questions. This information-- and there's a lot of it-- is then compiled into catalogs. Glossy pamphlets filled with men sorted by ethnicity or level of education, and then sent through the mail. Sometimes to infertile couples, sometimes to single women. People whose lives haven't worked out quite the way they had hoped, but who are ready to cut their losses, shelve their doubts, and proceed with plan B.
但首先需要填写表格——健康调查、家庭病史、问答题。这些信息（数量相当多）随后被汇编成目录。精美的册子，里面按种族或受教育程度对男人进行了分类，然后通过邮寄发送。有时发给不孕不育的夫妇，有时发给单身女性。这些人的人生并没有如他们所愿，但他们准备好减少损失，搁置怀疑，推进B计划。
This isn't about falling in love with some guy. It's about making a very scientific decision.
这与爱上某个男人无关。这是关于做一个非常科学的决定。
On the first page of my reporter's notebook, under the heading Karen in Brooklyn, there are these three words-- organized, tasteful, and fantasy.
在我的记者笔记本的第一页，在“布鲁克林的凯伦”标题下，有这三个词——有条理、有品位、幻想。
The first two words refer to Karen's apartment, a spacious one-bedroom in a fancy apartment house two blocks from the park in Park Slope, Brooklyn. The third word, fantasy, refers to something that Karen said to me in the first five minutes of our interview. She assured me, in the most reasonable tone possible, that the traditional idea of parenthood was a myth, a bill of goods we sold ourselves in order to bolster the illusion of control.
前两个词指的是凯伦的公寓，一套宽敞的一居室，位于布鲁克林公园坡公园旁两个街区的一栋豪华公寓楼里。第三个词“幻想”，指的是凯伦在采访开始的前五分钟里对我说的某件事。她用最理性的语气向我保证，传统的父母观念是一个神话，是我们为了支撑控制的错觉而向自己兜售的商品。
You think because you marry somebody and you love them and you get together and you're going to have a child that you can in some way predict what your kid's going to be like. But you can't. Your kid's going to be something else. Your kid's going to be its own thing. Every parent I've ever spoken to has told me that their kid sort of came out fully formed, just the way that they are. And that the kid just sort of unfolds. So there's no more guarantee that I'm going to be able to identify what my kid's going to be like by picking a donor as there is by picking a husband.
你以为因为你嫁给了某人，你爱他们，你们在一起了，要生个孩子，你就能以某种方式预测你的孩子会是什么样。但你不能。你的孩子会是别的样子。你的孩子会是其自身。我采访过的每位父母都告诉我，他们的孩子生出来时某种程度上就已经完全定型了，就是他们现在的样子。孩子只是在成长。所以，挑选捐赠者能识别出孩子会是什么样，并不比挑选丈夫更有保障。
Armed with this idea, Karen developed a theory. I'll call it the theory of genetic variety. She believed that the health of her child would be substantially improved if she could find a donor who was the genetic opposite of herself. As an Eastern European Jew, she was therefore searching, she told me, for something along the lines of Cuban Swede, or maybe, Siberian Argentinian.
带着这个想法，凯伦发展出了一种理论。我称之为基因多样性理论。她认为，如果她能找到一个与自己基因相反的捐赠者，她孩子的健康状况会大大改善。作为一名东欧犹太人，她告诉我，她正在寻找类似“古巴裔瑞典人”或者“西伯利亚裔阿根廷人”的人。
She talked about this theory for a pretty long time, carefully emphasizing that this process was not about love, but about locating what she called "a little genetic material." Then she brought out the folders, a stack of catalogs almost a foot high which Karen had ranked using a system of checks and x's. We begin at the top.
她谈论这个理论谈了很长时间，小心翼翼地强调这个过程不是关于爱，而是关于定位她所说的“一点基因材料”。然后她拿出了文件夹，那是厚度近一英尺的目录，凯伦用勾和叉的系统对它们进行了排名。我们从顶部开始。
Brown eyes, brown straight hair, medium skin tone. And then his education. This guy had a bachelor's in psychology. A lot of them are students, so you're not going to get much-- their occupation is probably what they want to be rather than what they are.
棕色眼睛，直棕发，中等肤色。还有他的教育程度。这家伙有心理学学士学位。他们中很多人是学生，所以你不会得到太多信息——他们的职业可能更反映他们想成为什么，而不是他们现在的身份。
Now that's kind of interesting to me. I mean, did it feel weird to you at all that you would be having a child with a much younger man?
这对我来说很有趣。我是说，你会和一个年轻得多的男人生孩子，这感觉奇怪吗？
Oh my god, it's so bizarre.
天哪，这太离奇了。
I should mention here that although Karen looks extremely young, with a small thin frame and smooth tan face, she's actually 39.
我应该在这里提一下，虽然凯伦看起来非常年轻，身材瘦小，皮肤光滑黝黑，但她其实已经39岁了。
When I saw if they felt really young and boyish for whatever reason, I couldn't use them. I had to pass.
当我看到他们无论出于什么原因感觉真的很年轻、很孩子气时，我就不能用他们。我必须放弃。
Even though it's just genetic material?
即使这只是基因材料？
Absolutely. I couldn't control-- I didn't predict that seeing the age would send this really weird feeling through me, but it just did. And I went to my email group about this and a lot of other women shared this same feeling, that it just feels funny. I want to almost say incestuous. I want to almost say-- what's the word? Not incestuous, but there's a word for that when you--
绝对。我无法控制——我没料到看到年龄会给我带来这种非常奇怪的感觉，但它确实发生了。我去我的电子邮件群里讨论了这个，很多其他女性分享了同样的感受，觉得这感觉很有意思。我几乎想说乱伦。我几乎想说——那个词是什么？不是乱伦，但当你……时有一个词。
Illegal?
违法的？
Yeah, exactly. It's like, statutory rape.
对，没错。就像是法定强奸。
It was a sentiment which didn't square very well with the notion of scientific process. After all, the sperm of an 18-year-old is no more or less mature than the sperm of an 88-year-old, as Karen herself admits.
这种情绪与科学过程的概念并不太吻合。毕竟，正如凯伦自己承认的那样，18岁男性的精子与88岁男性的精子并没有什么成熟度上的差别。
You know, even though this is a process that I have tried to make very sort of organized and scientific, there's this part of you that you can't really control and you can't really predict. And it just leaps out and you're like, I don't like this guy. I don't know why.
你知道，尽管这是一个我努力使之变得非常有条理和科学的过程，但你内心深处有部分是你无法真正控制和预测的。它突然冒出来，你会觉得，我不喜欢这家伙。我不知道为什么。
That part of Karen, which she could not really control or predict, kept intruding on her search, no matter what her best intentions were. There was the problem of the red-headed donor, for example, a man who was clearly an inappropriate choice, but whose red hair attracted Karen because it reminded her of a college boyfriend.
凯伦无法真正控制或预测的那部分自我，无论她意愿多么好，总是在她的搜寻过程中不断干扰。比如那个红头发捐赠者的问题，这个男人显然是个不合适的选择，但他的红头发吸引了凯伦，因为这让她想起了大学时的男朋友。
Then one day, Karen stumbled on another donor. His test scores weren't as high as some others. His family had some health problems which gave Karen pause. Still, there was something in his essay answers which caught Karen's eye, a quality of speech that she found somehow familiar.
然后有一天，凯伦偶然发现了另一个捐赠者。他的考试成绩不如其他人高。他的家庭有一些健康问题，这让凯伦犹豫了。尽管如此，他在问答题中的回答中有些东西引起了凯伦的注意，一种她觉得以某种方式很熟悉的说话质感。
You know, and he named all these nuanced ways of experiencing the world. I just thought, oh, wow. This guy's complicated in a way that I'm complicated and that I appreciate completely in other people. He just felt completely right. And he was my guy. That was the guy.
你知道，他命名了所有这些体验世界的细微差别。我当时就想，哦，哇。这家伙的复杂方式和我一样，而且我在其他人身上非常欣赏这种复杂。他感觉完全对了。他就是我的那个人。就是他。
After her decision, Karen found herself thinking about her donor more and more. She read over his information packet and talked about him frequently with friends.
做出决定后，凯伦发现自己越来越多地想到她的捐赠者。她反复阅读他的信息包，并经常和朋友谈论他。
You know, I knew what the sister did and that she had a kid. And I started thinking, oh, this is cool. Look at all the languages they speak. And I played violin and he plays violin. And I felt like it was good and right and positive. And I just thought it was going to work out well, that I was bringing good stuff to a kid.
你知道，我知道他姐姐做什么，而且她有孩子。我开始想，哦，这很酷。看看他们说的所有语言。我拉过小提琴，他也拉小提琴。我觉得这很好、很正确且积极。我只是觉得这会成功，我在给孩子带来好的东西。
And then I called up one day to order. I used to order in batches, like a couple-- not just one at a time, but I was trying to psych myself out by over-ordering. You know, because I figured I'd rather get stuck with extra sperm than no kid. So let's do it that way. And I just called up, after I'd gotten my period yet again. And I called up to order some more. They were like, oh, it's not available. And I was like, what?
然后有一天我打电话订购。我过去常按批次订购，比如几个——不是一次一个，我试图通过超额订购来让自己安心。因为我想，我宁愿多存点精子也不愿没孩子。所以就这样做吧。在我又一次月经后，我打电话过去订购更多。他们说，哦，已经没货了。我说，什么？
Now, everybody will tell you be prepared for this. I was totally unprepared. I had gotten so attached to this donor that I think I cried. I think I just sat down and cried.
现在，每个人都会告诉你对此要有心理准备。我完全没准备好。我对这个捐赠者产生了如此深的依恋，我想我哭了。我想我只是坐下来哭了起来。
Without meaning to, without even being fully aware of her own behavior, Karen had gotten attached and transformed her donor into a kind of phantom boyfriend. This isn't uncommon. Several of the women I spoke to described a similar attachment to their first donors. And like the others, after her first pick evaporated, Karen felt a profound sense of loss. She cursed. She cried. Then Karen got out her catalogs and looked again. But this time she didn't dawdle over essay questions. Karen did it by the numbers.
无意之中，甚至没有完全意识到自己的行为，凯伦产生了依恋，并将她的捐赠者变成了一种幻影男友。这并不罕见。我采访过的几位女性都描述了对自己第一位捐赠者的类似依恋。而且像其他人一样，在她的第一人选消失后，凯伦感到了一种深深的失落。她咒骂。她哭泣。然后凯伦拿出她的目录重新查看。但这一次，她没有在问答题上磨蹭。凯伦完全按指标办事。
My second donor, he's a much more elite guy. Because that stuff is just easy to jump on. This guy's got a doctorate. He speaks like four languages. He's obviously brilliant.
我的第二个捐赠者，他是一个更精英的人。因为那些东西很容易判断。这家伙有博士学位。他会说四种语言。他显然很聪明。
Do you feel less emotionally attached to this second donor?
你对这第二个捐赠者的情感依恋会少一些吗？
I do. I do.
确实少了。是的。
And this created its own problem. Karen wanted some kind of connection, something which would allow her to feel that the father of her child was not simply a random stranger in a sperm bank. Which is actually what he was. But a worthy man, someone to respect and be proud of.
这就产生了它自己的问题。凯伦想要某种联系，一种让她觉得她孩子的父亲不仅仅是精子库里的随机陌生人——这实际上就是他的身份——而是一个值得尊敬和骄傲的有价值的男人。
Put another way, Karen wanted some story which explained her choice. A story that she could tell to herself. A story that someday, she could tell to her child. It was what she had to offer in lieu of something more substantive and she wanted to get it right. In fact, this need for a connection, for some narrative which justifies the choice, is so profound, so important to this process, that Karen has decided to improvise a relationship with her second donor.
换句话说，凯伦想要一个解释她选择的故事。一个她可以告诉自己的故事。一个未来有一天，她可以告诉她孩子的故事。这是她在缺少实质性东西的情况下所能提供的，她想把这件事做好。事实上，这种对联系的需求，对某种能证明选择合理性的叙事的需求，是如此深刻，对这个过程如此重要，以至于凯伦决定即兴创作一段与她第二个捐赠者的关系。
The brilliant doctoral student with high marks in everything is originally from Spain. So Karen is planning a trip, a kind of ghost honeymoon with the idea of a dad, performed for a baby not yet born.
那个各科成绩都很高的聪明博士生最初来自西班牙。所以凯伦正在计划一次旅行，一种鬼魂式的蜜月，怀揣着一个父亲的构想，为还未出生的宝宝进行。
If I get pregnant with this donor, I will probably go to Barcelona and go to that region. Just so that I can have done that while I was pregnant with this child whose father probably came from that region. Just so I could have that to share with this kid.
如果我怀上了这个捐赠者的孩子，我可能会去巴塞罗那和那个地区。就为了能在怀着这个父亲很可能来自那个地区的孩子时完成这件事。就为了能和这个孩子分享这些。
And that'll be the way that you communicate his father to him?
那就是你向他传达他父亲的方式？
And I'll take a lot of pictures and I'll say, I don't know where-- but you know, this is where they're from. These are your people. And I'll go back with the kid. As soon as the kid's ready to travel, we'll go there. We'll go there and I'll say, this is where your family's from. Part of your family's from here.
我会拍很多照片，我会说，我不知道在哪里——但你知道，这是他们来自的地方。这些人是你的族人。孩子准备好旅行后，我会带着孩子回去。我们会去那里，我会说，这是你家人的来源。你的一部分家人来自这里。
Increase your knowledge and you increase your grief is a Latin proverb I read once, and remember, I guess, because it seemed like a self-defeating way to open a book. But anyway, this is a lesson which Karen, and many of the other women I spoke to, seemed to understand intuitively as they went about choosing their donors.
增加知识即增加悲伤，这是我读过的一句拉丁谚语，我之所以记得，我想是因为这似乎是一种自我挫败的开书方式。但无论如何，这似乎是凯伦和我采访过的许多其他女性在选择捐赠者时直觉上就能理解的教训。
In addition to medical histories and essay questions, many of the sperm banks offer pictures, audiotapes, even videos of potential donors. But the women I spoke to didn't seem very interested in these options. Not one of the four wanted to see a picture. They didn't want to watch video interviews either. And only two had chosen to listen to audiotapes. At first this confused me. Then I talked to Jamie.
除了病史和问答题，许多精子库还提供照片、录音带，甚至是潜在捐赠者的录像。但我采访的女性似乎对这些选择不太感兴趣。四个人中没有一个想看照片。她们也不想看视频采访。只有两个人选择听录音带。起初这让我很困惑。然后我和杰米谈了谈。
I had no idea what I was going to go for. So I said, well, let me go-- if I could pick my husband, what he looks like, and if he was smart or not, that's what I'm going to kind of pick. So you know, tall, dark, handsome, Italian stud sounded good to me.
我根本不知道我要找什么样的。所以我想，好吧，如果我可以挑选我的丈夫，他长什么样，他是否聪明，这就是我打算挑选的。所以你知道，高大、英俊、意大利种马听起来对我来说不错。
Jamie is a hairdresser who lives in a comfortable old farmhouse in rural upstate New York. When I drive to her home, around 8:00 on a Tuesday night, there are so few lights in the area that it's sometimes difficult to see the road.
杰米是一位美发师，住在美国农村的一栋舒适的老农舍里。周二晚上8点左右我开车去她家时，该地区几乎没有灯光，有时很难看清路。
Sitting at her kitchen table, Jamie tells me that even though she's always been independent-- she started her own business in her early 20s-- she somehow knew that she wanted a family. It wasn't until her early 30s, though, when her best friend became pregnant with her third child, that Jamie decided that it was time to start a family of her own.
坐在厨房桌边，杰米告诉我，尽管她一直都很独立——她20出头就开始了自己的生意——但她不知何故知道自己想要一个家庭。不过，直到30岁出头，当她最好的朋友怀上第三个孩子时，杰米才决定是时候组建自己的家庭了。
She contacted a sperm bank and immediately found three men that seemed attractive. One donor in particular had caught Jamie's eye. And when the informational packets arrived, it was his tape that Jamie listened to first.
她联系了一家精子库，并很快找到了三个看起来很有吸引力的男人。其中一位捐赠者特别吸引了杰米的注意。当信息包寄到时，杰米第一个听的就是他的带子。
I listened to his and I was like, oh no. He just didn't sound like anybody that I would ever want to talk with. I don't know, he was just-- I don't know. It's hard to explain. It's just something that I couldn't connect with. I couldn't feel like, oh, he sounds really cool. Not at all. Not at all.
我听了他的带子，我就想，噢不。他听起来根本不像我想交谈的那种人。我不知道，他就是……我不知道。很难解释。就是某种我无法连接的感觉。我无法觉得，噢，他听起来真的很酷。一点也不。一点也不。
And then I said to myself, maybe the audiotapes aren't really a good idea. Maybe it's too much. Because maybe I'm really going to love them on paper and maybe it's going to totally change my outlook.
然后我对自己说，也许录音带并不是个好主意。也许这太过了。因为也许我在纸面上真的很喜欢他们，也许这会完全改变我的看法。
In that experience of kind of liking someone on paper and then listening to their audiotape, was that like--
在那种在纸面上喜欢某人然后听他们录音带的经历中，那是……
That was weird. That was definitely weird. That was weird. Because you know, like once you hear someone's voice it makes them real.
那很奇怪。那绝对很奇怪。那很怪。因为你知道，一旦你听到某人的声音，就让他们变得真实了。
If you ask Jamie to describe her donor, a man she's never seen, she'll tell you that she think he's about six feet tall. She'll say that he has curly brown hair and horn-rimmed glasses. And that when she thinks of him, she imagines him in a tomato garden, standing, laughing, his arm around his grandfather.
如果你让杰米描述她的捐赠者，一个她从未见过面的男人，她会告诉你，她觉得他身高大约六英尺。她会说他有一头卷曲的棕发和黑框眼镜。而且当她想到他时，她想象他在番茄园里，站着，笑着，胳膊搭在他祖父的肩上。
If you ask her, really push her, she'll also admit that she sometimes fantasizes that she meets this man and that they fall in love and get married, and live happily ever after with their child. But two seconds later, Jamie will tell you that she knows how ridiculous this sounds. That she doesn't take it seriously. That it's just a thought she had, one that doesn't mean anything.
如果你问她，真的逼问她，她也会承认她有时会幻想自己遇见了这个男人，他们坠入爱河并结婚，从此和他们的孩子过上幸福的生活。但两秒钟后，杰米会告诉你她知道这听起来有多荒唐。她并不认真对待这件事。这只是她脑子里闪过的一个念头，并不意味着什么。
Jamie is 32 years old. She allows herself this fantasy and should allow herself this fantasy because she know she's in no danger of mistaking it for a possible reality. But children are different. They're prone to hope and frequent victims of their own imagination.
杰米32岁。她允许自己有这种幻想，也应该允许，因为她知道她没有把这误认为现实的可能性。但孩子们不同。他们容易产生希望，也经常是自己想象力的受害者。
You know, I don't want them to have a picture in their head of somebody who didn't want to be with them. I want it to just be, OK, it was a man who let us borrow these special seeds. That it was very generous of him. But I don't want to tell the child, well, this is what I thought he looked like and this is where I think he lived. I don't want to paint that whole big fantasy picture for a kid, and then that person's not there.
你知道，我不希望他们脑子里有一个不想和他们在一起的人的形象。我希望这只是，好的，有一个男人借给了我们这些特别的种子。他非常慷慨。但我不想告诉孩子，嗯，这就是我想象中他长得样子，这就是我觉得他住的地方。我不希望为孩子描绘出那种宏大的幻想图景，而那个人却不在那里。
This is a situation where less is better. Better that the child not think too carefully about who or what his father is. Better that the women avoid pictures, avoid video. In fact, I would make a further argument, that perversely, even though creating a child is one of the most intimate things two people can do, this entire process depends on anonymity, on all parties remaining as abstract an abstraction as possible. To understand why this might be, consider the issue of the yes donor.
这是一种少即是多的情况。孩子最好不要太仔细地思考谁或什么是他的父亲。女性最好避免看照片，避免看视频。事实上，我还要进一步论证，奇怪的是，尽管创造孩子是两个人能做的最私密的事情之一，但整个过程依赖于匿名，依赖于所有各方尽可能保持抽象的抽象感。要理解为什么会这样，考虑一下“肯定型捐赠者”的问题。
A yes donor is sperm bank speak for a man who is willing to be contacted after the child turns 18. In other words, a potential real father that the kid could look forward to meeting.
“肯定型捐赠者”是精子库术语，指愿意在孩子年满18岁后被联系的男人。换句话说，是一个孩子可以期待见到的潜在真实父亲。
On the surface, the yes donor option seems like a good idea. It certainly seems like a better deal than never meeting your father at all. But when I ask Karen if she's ever considered using a yes donor, she looks down in her lap for a second and sighs a little before answering. Then she shakes her head no.
表面上看，肯定型捐赠者的选择听起来是个好主意。它看起来当然比永远见不到父亲要划算。但当我问凯伦是否考虑过使用肯定型捐赠者时，她低头看着自己的腿，叹了口气，然后才回答。接着她摇了摇头，表示拒绝。
When I made the decision to be a single mother, part of the challenge, part of what I knew I was giving to this kid that was something I was going to have to think deeply and confront again and again, was that I was bringing a kid into the world who is not going to know their father. Period. So the idea of someone who the kid could later contact, that wasn't appealing. Because the message that I'm going to have for this kid is, this is our family. Our family consists of me and you and our village. You know, the people around us who love us.
当我决定做单身母亲时，部分挑战，我意识到我给这个孩子的部分东西是我必须深入思考并不断面对的，那就是我带了一个永远不会知道自己父亲的孩子来到这个世界。句号。所以关于一个孩子以后可以联系某人的想法，那并不吸引人。因为我传达给这个孩子的信息是，这是我们的家庭。我们的家庭由我和你，还有我们的村庄组成。你知道，周围那些爱我们的人。
There's somebody who's your father. We'll never know who he is. He made a decision to do something for a woman like me and we're really grateful about that, but he's not your dad. And maybe that's something to grieve, something to be angry at me about. But I had a vision of having enormous love to offer you and I knew that we could get through this. And that was always what I thought I would bring to being a single mom.
有一个人是你的父亲。我们永远不会知道他是谁。他做出了为像我这样的女性做点什么的决定，我们对此非常感激，但他不是你的爸爸。也许这是值得哀伤、值得对我生气的事情。但我有一个愿景，就是能为你提供巨大的爱，而且我知道我们能熬过这一关。这就是我一直认为自己能带给单身母亲这个身份的东西。
So being able to hold out the promise to the kid that they can meet this person, it wasn't part of that. I couldn't imagine raising a kid to say, well, one day you'll meet your dad. Well, what if one day he meets his dad and he sucks? Or he's changed his mind and he's rejectful. I don't want to raise a kid with a fantasy where it's going to be blown to bits. The truth of the matter is, you know what? You don't have a dad. You have a lot of other things.
所以能够对孩子抱有可以见到这个人的承诺，那不是其中的一部分。我无法想象抚养一个孩子去说，嗯，总有一天你会见到你的爸爸。那么，如果有一天他真的见到他爸爸而发现那人是个渣男怎么办？或者他改变了主意，拒绝承认怎么办？我不希望在幻想中抚养一个孩子，然后让那幻想被击得粉碎。事实的真相是，你知道吗？你没有爸爸。你有很多其他的东西。
I know from my conversations with other single moms by choice that the relationship between a mother and her donor changes over time. And that even women resolutely indifferent to their donors during the selection process tend to soften after a child is born. On the message boards, the new mothers talk of the quote "mysterious connection" they suddenly feel to their donors, and write things like, "If I could only send him pictures," or "I wish that he could see."
从我与其他选择做单身母亲的女性的谈话中，我知道母亲和捐赠者之间的关系会随着时间推移而改变。而且即使是在选择过程中对捐赠者漠不关心的女性，在孩子出生后也往往会心软。在留言板上，新妈妈们谈论她们突然感觉到的所谓的“神秘联系”，并写下诸如“如果我只能寄照片给他”或者“我希望他能看到”之类的话。
Meanwhile the men, the financially strapped college sophomores, the hopeful actors, the future doctors, continue their lives more or less oblivious. They finish college and go on to graduate programs. They move from LA and switch to real estate. They become actual doctors and start their own practice without realizing that there are three, four, maybe five middle-aged women out there yearning to send them Polaroids of little Johnny's first tooth.
与此同时，那些男人们，那些经济拮据的大二学生、怀揣梦想的演员、未来的医生们，继续过着他们的生活，或多或少地浑然不觉。他们大学毕业，进入研究生课程。他们搬离洛杉矶，转行做房地产。他们成为真正的医生，开办自己的诊所，却完全没意识到外面有三、四个，甚至五个中年女性渴望着把小强尼的第一颗牙的照片发给他们。
After talking to a number of these women, I think about that sometimes. I think about lining up all the middle-aged women and all the 20-year-old men and letting them get a good look at one another. I think about the kids and the mean tricks an imagination can play when there's no reality, only absence. And then I think about Karen and I decide that she's right. That if I were a single mom I would say the same thing. You don't have a dad. A father, but not a dad. Your dad doesn't exist. But sit and try to remember, my dear, you have a lot of other things.
在和这些女性谈话后，我有时会想到这一点。我想到让所有中年女性和所有20岁的年轻男人排成一排，让他们好好看看对方。我想到孩子们，以及当现实缺失、只有缺席时想象力会玩的那些恶作剧。然后我想到凯伦，决定她是正确的。如果我是单身妈妈，我也会说同样的话。你没有爸爸。有一个生父，但没有爸爸。你的爸爸不存在。但坐下来试着记住，亲爱的，你有很多其他东西。
Alix Spiegel in New York.
阿利克斯·斯皮格尔，报道于纽约。
[MUSIC - "LIFE WITHOUT  A FATHER" BY TRAVOLTA W., KEVIN G., AND KEITH L.]
[音乐 - 特拉沃尔塔·W、凯文·G和基思·L表演的《没有父亲的生活》]
Case Two, Tell It to the Void.
案例二，告诉虚空。
As Alix Spiegel pointed out, at some point, some moms get a very pointed desire to send photos and information about their kids to forever absent dads. But exactly what information do they want the dads to know? And why, really, do they care if they know it?
正如阿利克斯·斯皮格尔所指出的，在某个时刻，一些妈妈会产生一种非常强烈的渴望，想把孩子的照片和信息寄给永远缺席的父亲。但她们到底想让父亲知道什么信息？为什么，说真的，她们在意父亲是否知道？
Well, not long ago, this website devoted to publishing letters from a wide variety of people, a site called openletters.net, published a series of letters from a woman in Winnipeg, Manitoba, who called herself X. That's the letter X. These were her dispatches to the father of her child. This father was somewhere out there. They detailed what the kid was doing these days. She called the kid O. His little sister was G. X's significant other was C. Here are some excerpts from some of the letters.
嗯，不久前，一个致力于出版各种各样的人写信的网站，一个叫openletters.net的网站，出版了一系列来自温尼伯曼尼托巴省一位女性的信件，她称自己为X。就是字母X。这些是她发给孩子父亲的快件。这位父亲在某个地方。信里详细说明了孩子这些天在做什么。她称孩子为O。他的小妹妹是G。X的另一半是C。以下是其中一些信件的节选。
Dear Mike, he's 13 and 1/2, which you probably know, and things are happening.
亲爱的迈克，他13岁半了，你可能知道，事情正在发生。
So first thing this morning, when his eyes opened and his sheet is, as always, inexplicably half off his bed, he grabs his CD remote control and pushes play and we hear Fat Boy Slim all over the house. Same house as always, only it's red and yellow now, not blue.
所以今天一早，当他睁开眼睛，床单像往常一样莫名其妙地滑落了一半，他抓起CD遥控器按下播放键，我们就听到了肥仔瘦身乐队的音乐响彻整间屋子。还是那座房子，只是现在漆成了红色和黄色，不再是蓝色了。
He comes downstairs all arms and legs and skinny. He's tall, taller than me, in his Joe Boxer boxers and sits at the dining room table eating Honey Nut Cheerios and reading yesterday's comics. He has the number 60 on his leg in black marker. That was his number yesterday at the provincial basketball tryouts, which he didn't make, due to lack of confidence, said the coach, though he's got the moves. And next year he'll be older and ready.
他走下楼，手长脚长，瘦骨嶙峋。他很高，比我还高，穿着Joe Boxer平角裤，坐在餐桌旁吃着蜂蜜坚果脆脆圈，看昨天的漫画。他的腿上有用黑色记号笔写着的数字60。那是他昨天参加省级篮球选拔赛时的号码，他没入选，教练说是因为缺乏自信，尽管他有那动作。明年他会更大，准备得更充分。
It doesn't bug him. None of his friends made it this year. And his school coach had told them they wouldn't, but that it would be a good experience. That's what he and his friend said to each other after the tryout.
这没困扰他。他的朋友今年一个都没入选。校队教练之前也告诉他们不会入选，但这会是一次很好的体验。这就是他和他朋友在选拔赛后对彼此说的话。
"Hey, good experience, eh?"
“嘿，很好的体验，呃？”
"Oh, yeah. Excellent experience."
“哦，是啊。卓越的体验。”
"Now that was a good experience."
“那确实是一次很好的体验。”
They're pretty funny.
他们真是太有趣了。
He's got a choice this morning for lunch. Bagel and cream cheese, turkey sandwich, or peanut butter and banana sandwich. He chooses peanut butter and banana. He plays around with the dog for a while, tells G., his 10-year-old sister, who's getting ready for running club, that when he had running club, they ran in the rain because they were tougher back then. And then he checks out his reflection in the toaster oven and off he goes to catch his bus for school.
他今天早上午餐有个选择。百吉饼配奶油芝士，火鸡三明治，或者花生酱香蕉三明治。他选了花生酱香蕉。他跟狗玩了一会儿，告诉正在准备跑步俱乐部的10岁妹妹G，说他参加跑步俱乐部时，因为那时候更坚强，他们是在雨中跑步。然后他在烤箱的玻璃上照了照自己的倒影，就去赶校车了。
"Have a good day," I tell him.
“祝你今天过得愉快，”我对他说。
And he says, "You too." I can't call out to him after he's left the house with "I love you" or "Do you have your lunch?" This mortifies him.
他说：“你也是。”他出门后我没法喊着说“我爱你”或“你带午餐了吗？”这让他感到尴尬。
Later today he's got a different basketball practice for the regional team and he's going to miss his baseball game go to the basketball practice. His baseball team is called the Sabres and he pitches and catches. And he's a great pitcher with a wicked curve, although he prefers to catch. And if you could see him make the throw from home plate to second, you'd know how good he is.
今天晚些时候他有另一场区域球队的篮球练习，他为了去练球要错过棒球赛。他的棒球队叫军刀队，他负责投球和接球。他是个伟大的投手，球路刁钻，尽管他更喜欢接球。如果你能看他从本垒传向二垒，你就知道他有多棒。
Then I guess he'll come home and eat ice cream and chocolate sauce and watch some bad television. He loves the Comedy Channel, and Letterman, he loves Letterman too, and thinks it's cool that Letterman and Nolan Ryan and his grandma all had the same kind of heart surgery.
我想他回来后会吃冰淇淋加巧克力酱，看一些糟糕的电视节目。他喜欢喜剧频道，还有莱特曼，他也喜欢莱特曼，觉得莱特曼、诺兰·瑞恩和他祖母做了同一种心脏手术这事很酷。
Maybe check out something on the net, like the phone number of that phone booth in the middle of the desert so he can call it some day. And then go to bed after some kidding around. And he'll call out from his freshly painted green and charcoal bedroom, "Hey, whoever put my sheet back on, thanks."
也许会去网上查点什么，比如沙漠中间那个电话亭的号码，这样他有一天可以打过去。然后在大闹一番后上床睡觉。他会从刚漆成绿色和炭黑色的卧室里喊道：“嘿，不管是谁帮我把床单铺好的，谢了。”
I know you want to know one thing, but I'm not going to tell you whether he talks about you or not, or what he even remembers. I've tried to keep track of you through your brother, but I don't think he lives here anymore either. Where do you live? Japan, still, or what? Australia? Like you'd tell me. I'm not asking for money. I'm not asking for anything. I just want to tell you about your kid before there's no kid left and we're both 100 years old. It seems so stupid not to talk. Keep a stiff upper lip. There are a million things I could tell you. But you don't get to choose. Signed, X.
我知道你想知道一件事，但我不会告诉你他是否提起过你，或者他到底还记得什么。我试着通过你弟弟追踪你，但我想他也不住这儿了。你住哪？还是日本？澳大利亚？像你会告诉我一样。我不是要钱。我不是要任何东西。我只是想在孩子还没长大，我们都100岁之前告诉你关于你的孩子。不谈话看起来太蠢了。保持坚强。有数百万件事我可以告诉你。但你没法选择。签名，X。
Dear Mike, he's not here right now. He's over at my mom's watching The Usual Suspects and recovering from the Cobra, which is a killer ride at this carnival we found today downtown next to the river. He can't handle those rides very well, but he agreed to go on the Cobra with his sister twice, which I thought was sweet. Afterwards, he lurched back to the van clutching his bottle of Coke and making fake barfing sounds and saying stuff like, "Anything for the kid." And "I just remember how no one would go with me on the Cobra when I was a--" barfing noise-- "kid." And more barfing. "I just couldn't do that to her," falling on the grass motionless.
亲爱的迈克，他现在不在。他在我妈家看《非常嫌疑犯》，从眼镜蛇过山车中恢复过来，那是我们在市中心河边发现的嘉年华里最恐怖的项目。他很难适应那些项目，但他同意陪妹妹坐了两次眼镜蛇过山车，我觉得这很贴心。之后，他踉跄着回到面包车，抓着一瓶可乐，发出假装呕吐的声音，说着诸如“为了孩子，一切都值了”。还有“我只记得当我还是个……”——呕吐声——“孩子的时候，没人愿意陪我坐眼镜蛇。”更多呕吐声。“我就是没法那样对她，”然后无力地倒在草地上。
Really sweet because G. giggled and said that when he was being nice to her he was the best brother in the world.
真的太贴心了，因为G咯咯笑着说，当他对他妹妹好的时候，他是世界上最好的哥哥。
The other day he bought himself a hat that said Porn Star on it. And I was kind of upset about it and I asked him not to wear it. Then my sister and my mom also asked him not to wear it and he said, "Man, would you just all relax?"
前几天他给自己买了一顶写着“色情明星”的帽子。我有点不高兴，请他别戴。然后我妹妹和我妈也请他别戴，他说：“天哪，你们能不能都放松点？”
"But, O.," I said, "Do you know what a porn star is?"
“但，O，”我说，“你知道什么是色情明星吗？”
"No, mom," he said. "What's a porn star?"
“不知道，妈妈，”他说。“什么是色情明星？”
And I said, "Well, OK, it's when a person becomes very good at--"
我说：“好吧，是当一个人变得非常擅长于……”
And he said, "Yes, mother. I know what a porn star is. I was kidding. God." And then he told me it was a brand, just a brand. Or maybe he said a band. I can't remember.
他说：“是的，妈妈。我知道什么是色情明星。我开玩笑的。天哪。”然后他告诉我那是个品牌，只是个品牌。也许他说的是个乐队。我记不清了。
And I said, "Well, OK. I'm going to get a Porn Star hat for me, too. And one for Auntie M. and one for Grandma. And we'll all wear them if it's just a brand."
我说：“好吧，行。我也要去买一顶色情明星帽子。还要给M阿姨买一顶，给奶奶买一顶。如果那只是个品牌，我们都戴。”
"Fill your boots," he said, and stalked off.
“随你便，”他说，气冲冲地走了。
So it was kind of a dilemma. Take his hat away or just let it go. Or buy him a different one. I suggested that, a different one, and he said, "Yeah, please get me the one with Paddington the Bear on it."
所以这成了一个难题。收走他的帽子还是就这样算了。或者给他买一顶别的。我建议买个别的，他说：“好吧，请给我买个带帕丁顿熊的吧。”
So finally, my sister called and she said she'd give him $20 not to wear the Porn Star hat. And he said he'd think about it. The next thing I know my sister's beaming and he's $20 richer. How pathetic is that? What do you think you'd have done? Have you ever heard of that brand in Uganda or Greenland or wherever you are?
最后，我妹妹打电话来说，她给20美元让他不戴那顶色情明星帽子。他说他会考虑一下。下一刻我发现我妹妹笑逐颜开，他赚了20美元。这有多可悲？你觉得你会怎么做？在乌干达、格陵兰岛或你所在的任何地方，你听说过那个品牌吗？
Now when we see a kid with a Porn Star t-shirt or hat or bumper sticker, O. says to me, "Go get them, mom."
现在当我们看到戴着色情明星T恤、帽子或保险杠贴纸的孩子时，O会对我说：“去抓住他们，妈妈。”
Today's my birthday and I'm drinking orange juice and champagne right now. He stayed up till 2:00 in the morning last night making me a mix tape of songs he knew I'd like-- stuff like Randy Newman and Paul Westerberg and Tom Waits, and the new Neil Young and even the Clash. And it's so sweet because he actually had to listen to all these old guys while he made it, which was a form of torture for him. So it means a lot.
今天是我的生日，我正在喝橙汁加香槟。他昨晚熬夜到凌晨2点，给我录了一盘混音带，都是他知道我会喜欢的歌——兰迪·纽曼、保罗·韦斯特伯格、汤姆·威茨，还有新尼尔·杨，甚至是撞击乐队。这太贴心了，因为他录的时候不得不听这些老家伙的歌，对他来说这简直是折磨。所以这意义重大。
I'm listening to "Christmas Card" right now, Tom Waits. You remember. You do. The strange thing is, I can't remember your birthday. We were together long enough to put together this funny, intense, shy kid who stays up late making compilation tapes for his old lady, but not long enough for me to remember the day you were born. Was it April something?
我现在正听着汤姆·威茨的《圣诞卡片》。你记得。你记得。奇怪的是，我不记得你的生日了。我们在一起的时间足够长，可以一起生下这个有趣、敏感、害羞的孩子，他熬夜为他老妈录制混音带，却不够长让我记得你出生那天的日期。是四月某号吗？
So today I'm 36 and you get to stay 23 forever, in black faded Levi's and an SNFU t-shirt and Converse sneakers, smoking an Export A and cooking penny wieners in some [BLEEP] apartment kitchen with the Cramps playing and no furniture.
所以今天我36岁了，你永远定格在23岁，穿着褪色的黑色牛仔裤，SNFU T恤和匡威运动鞋，抽着出口A香烟，在某个[消音]公寓厨房里煮热狗，放着Cramps乐队的音乐，屋里没有家具。
Soon I'll be old enough to be your mother. Sometimes I do think I see you on the street. And if I'm with O. I sometimes look over at him and wonder if he thinks he sees you too. If he remembers much from when he was what? Four or five and you went mini-golfing with him and then left forever. And I want to ask him, but at the same time I don't want to ask him.
很快我就能当你妈妈了。有时我确实觉得我在街上看到了你。如果我和O在一起，我有时会看向他，想他是否觉得他也看到了你。如果他记得他什么年纪时的很多事？四岁还是五岁，那时你和他去玩迷你高尔夫，然后永远离开了。我想问他，但同时我又不想问。
You take up a lot of room for a guy who's not here. Later, mystery man. X.
对于一个不在场的人来说，你占用了太多空间。回头见，神秘人。X。
Dear Mike, you know I was thinking about this letter thing and it occurred to me that if you're ever going to respond, you'd need kind of an amnesty deal, like libraries have to return way overdue books. Which means you don't have to go over the last 10 years pointing out all the stuff that happened that made you leave and not maintain contact and all that. Or blame yourself or seek redemption. We could just start again as of now.
亲爱的迈克，你知道我一直在思考这写信的事，我突然想到如果有一天你要回复，你需要某种大赦协议，就像图书馆有还清逾期图书的规定一样。这意味着你不需要把过去10年重头捋一遍，指出所有让你离开且不保持联系的事情，或者责备自己，寻找救赎。我们可以从现在重新开始。
Because if we have to dredge up all the old [BLEEP] just to get to a place where we can talk normally again or whatever, it may never happen. Too overwhelming. So if you want to leave the old [BLEEP] alone and just start now, that's OK. That's perfect. It's just a thought, if you're even out there. If you're even alive.
因为如果我们必须把过去所有的[消音]都挖出来才能达到能正常交流的地步，那可能永远也不会发生。太让人无法承受了。所以如果你想放下过去的[消音]直接开始，那没关系。那很完美。这只是个想法，如果你还在外面。如果你还活着。
But here's a story of O.'s blossoming maturity. He's playing baseball for the Sabres and he's pitching in the third inning. He does well, three up, three down. So next inning, two out. He's up to bat and bam, he hits a home run. He's flying around the bases and makes it home and sits down on the bench while his teammates hit him on the back and high fives. All that.
但这里有个关于O日益成熟的故事。他代表军刀队打棒球，第三局他投球。他表现不错，三上三下。下一局，两出局。他上场击球，砰，他击出了一个本垒打。他飞奔过垒包，回到本垒，坐在板凳上，队友们拍着他的背，击掌。就是那一套。
But wait, something's up. The ump comes over, calls him out on second because apparently he didn't touch the base. So that's the third out, which means he goes to pitch immediately. He's looking OK. Cool. But he's rattled. Obviously, as he starts throwing wild balls all over. Except not over home plate. His coach pulls him and puts him on third. New pitcher. So that's the thing, maturity. Not that he became rattled. That's normal. But that he tried not to show it.
但等等，出事了。裁判过来，宣布他二垒出局，因为显然他没踩到垒包。所以那是第三个出局，意味着他必须立刻去投球。他看起来还行。冷静。但他慌了。显然，他开始乱投球。除了不到本垒板上。教练把他换下场，让他守三垒。换了新投手。所以这就是那件事，成熟度。不是因为他慌了。那很正常。而是他努力不表现出来。
It was only evident in his pitching, not in his language, body language, that stuff. But his pitching couldn't hide it. That's what sports is all about in my mind, accepting the call and shaking it off. At least outwardly.
这只在他投球时表现出来，而不是在他的语言或肢体语言中。但他的投球掩盖不了。这就是我心目中体育的意义，接受判罚并把它甩在脑后。至少在表面上。
Last year he would have been swearing, probably, and throwing his glove on the ground. That sort of thing. Not this year. And then, on top of it all, at the end of the game, I went over to him and said, "Tough call. I bet you did touch second." And he said, no, actually he hadn't. He said the ump was right. Unbelievable. That's your kid, you know. That's the story of O.'s blossoming maturity. Got to go. X.
去年他可能会开始咒骂，把手套扔在地上。那种事。今年没有。而且更重要的是，比赛结束时，我走过去对他说：“判罚太严了。我打赌你踩到二垒了。”他说，不，其实没有。他说裁判是对的。不可思议。这就是你的孩子，你知道。这就是O日益成熟的故事。得走了。X。
Dear Mike, more really big news. Last night O.'s school had its sports banquet and awards evening, which included dinner and dancing. And O. got three trophies, which were the Coach's Award for junior boys basketball, which basically means hardest working and most versatile. He's a wing like Vince Carter and Kobe Bryant are wings. MVP for junior boys volleyball. And get this, Male Athlete of the Year for grade eight. I can't even explain how wrong it is that you don't know this stuff. Unless, of course, you're reading this letter. Which you probably aren't. Which makes me wonder why I bother with this exercise. That's right, tell the void how much your son rocks.
亲爱的迈克，还有真正的大新闻。昨晚O的学校举行了体育宴会和颁奖之夜，包括晚餐和跳舞。O得了三个奖杯，分别是初中男生篮球教练奖，这基本意味着最勤奋和最多面手。他是侧翼球员，像文斯·卡特和科比·布莱恩特那样。初中男生排球最有价值球员。还有，注意听，八年级年度最佳男运动员。我甚至无法解释你不知道这些东西有多荒谬。除非，当然，你在读这封信。而你可能没在读。这让我怀疑我为什么要做这个练习。没错，告诉虚空你的儿子有多棒。
C. Told him how proud he was of him and that he didn't have to do sports if he didn't want to, if he wasn't having fun. And that if he quit all sports today, we'd still love him and still be proud of him. And C. told him how great it was that he was controlling his temper in the games when he lost, or after a bad call, or whatever. And O. said, "I'm just storing it up." And C. Said, "Oh, what are you going to do, explode on the court someday?" And O. said, "Oh, no. Way worse than that." And C. said, "Spit in the ump's face?" And O. said, "Oh, no. Way worse than that."
C告诉他他为他感到多骄傲，如果他不想参加体育活动也没关系，如果他觉得不开心的话。如果他今天退出所有运动，我们依然爱他，依然为他感到骄傲。C还告诉他，他在比赛中输球、或判罚不公时能控制情绪真是太棒了。O说：“我只是把它存起来。”C说：“哦，你是打算有一天在球场上爆发吗？”O说：“哦，不。比那严重多了。”C说：“吐裁判口水？”O说：“哦，不。比那严重多了。”
OK, he was joking, but it reminded me of when you said you used to lose your temper all the time. And then around 12 or 13, after throwing a plate or a bottle of ketchup at your older sister who had taken your Ski-Doo suit or something, you just went, "OK, that's it. I'm not going to get mad anymore. It doesn't help me. It makes it worse. I get in trouble. I look like an idiot and it's stupid." And then, sure enough, I'm trying to think of one time you got mad and I can't. You never got mad. Even when I was such a jerk and stuff was happening. You just put on music and cooked meat and smoked cigarettes and what?
好吧，他在开玩笑，但这让我想起你说你过去总是发脾气。然后在12或13岁左右，在你朝拿了你滑雪服或什么的姐姐扔盘子或番茄酱瓶后，你只是说：“好吧，就这样。我再也不发火了。这对我没帮助。它只会让情况更糟。我惹麻烦。我看起来像个白痴，这太蠢了。”然后，果然，我试着想一件你生气的事，却想不出来。你从不生气。即使当我是个混蛋，事情在发生时。你只是放音乐，做肉吃，抽香烟，然后呢？
Remember when I freaked out and drove myself to the hospital to have O. Because I thought you were too relaxed about the whole thing? And you ran all the way, all those miles of city blocks to the hospital and came in all sweating and red and purple. And I was already dilated and the nurse said you looked like John Lennon. And you said, "I'm here. I'm here." And I said some asshole thing and you said, "Come on. Look what's happening here. This is big. Don't be mad now."
还记得我发疯，自己开车去医院生O吗？因为我觉得你对整件事太放松了。你一路跑来，跑过了好几个街区的城市街道赶到医院，进来时汗流浃背，满脸通红发紫。我那时已经开宫口了，护士说你看起来像约翰·列侬。你说：“我来了。我来了。”我说了句混蛋话，你说：“快点。看这里发生了什么。这很重大。现在别生气。”
All right, that made a lot of sense. But Mike, it's still big. He's still here, still happening. So don't you be mad now.
好吧，那很有道理。但迈克，它依然重大。他还在这里，依然在发生。所以你现在别生气。
See, I'm trying to learn more about O. by remembering what I can of you. It's a little uncanny sometimes how some things are really similar, like this anger thing. Just out of the blue the kid stopped losing his temper at the same age you decided to stop losing your temper. So where does it go when you stop losing it?
你看，我试图通过回忆我所能记住的关于你的事来了解O。有时有些事情真的非常相似，这有点不可思议，比如这发火的事情。孩子突然在和你决定不再发火的相同年龄停止了发火。所以当你停止发火时，那气去哪了？
It would be so cool if you could get back to me, really. I mean, not me. Him. Or me first. Or whatever. Not for some romantic thing. Don't get the wrong idea. C. and me are great, and you're probably married with other athletic kids. Sometimes I wonder if you just decided that it would be best if you slipped away forever, best for O. and me and that you really, really believed that.
如果你能回复我会很酷，真的。我是说，不是我。他。或者先是我。或者什么的。不是为了什么浪漫的事。别误会。C和我很好，你可能也结婚了，有其他运动型小孩。有时我怀疑你是否只是决定如果悄悄溜走永远消失是最好的，对O和我觉得最好的，并且你真的真的相信那一点。
Remember when I stood on the sidewalk in front of my house with O. on my hip? He was about two years old and I screamed my stupid head off at you while you walked away without saying a word. Maybe you were thinking, "This is nuts. This poor kid. I've got to go." That would've made sense at the time, right?
还记得我站在屋前的人行道上，怀里抱着O吗？他大约两岁，我冲你尖叫我的蠢话，而你走开了，一言不发。也许你在想，“这太疯了。这可怜的孩子。我必须走。”那在当时说得通，对吧？
But you know, I've calmed down since then. Even though I was a lot older than 13 when I figured out that losing my temper wasn't getting me anywhere. X in Winnipeg.
但你知道，从那时起我已经冷静下来了。尽管我发现发脾气没用的时候已经比13岁大多了。温尼伯的X。
Dear Mike, well, summer's almost over and as usual, odd things have been happening. This is the latest. Your dad called here, right out of the blue. Haven't seen or talked to him since O. was an infant and you and I took that road trip when you barfed in the hotel bathtub. And he told us that he lived in Australia now, but he was in town and would really like to see O. if O. would like to see him.
亲爱的迈克，嗯，夏天快结束了，像往常一样，发生了些奇怪的事。这是最近的一件。你爸爸打电话来，突如其来。自O还是婴儿，你和我那次开车旅行在旅馆浴缸里吐了以后，就再也没见过他或和他说话了。他告诉我们他现在住在澳大利亚，但他在城里，如果O想见他，他真的希望能见见O。
O. said no. Not because he didn't want to see him really, but because he just didn't know why or what purpose it would serve. And your dad totally understood and said if O. ever changes his mind, he'd be glad. He'd wait.
O说了不。不是因为他不想见他，而是因为他只是不知道为什么，也不明白有什么意义。你爸爸完全理解，说如果O有一天改变主意，他会很高兴。他会等。
I asked him if you were happy, and he said, yes, very. That you live in Tokyo. That you're a very successful chef, an executive chef, he said. In a hotel with 550 rooms. And that you're married to a wonderful Japanese woman and that you have a beautiful three-year-old daughter. And that you'd probably never leave Tokyo. He said he'd send O. a picture of you and your wife and your daughter. He called her O.'s sister.
我问他你快乐吗，他说，是的，非常快乐。你住在东京。你是位非常成功的厨师，他说，是行政总厨。在一家拥有550个房间的旅馆里。而且你娶了一位出色的日本妻子，有一个漂亮的3岁女儿。而且你可能永远不会离开东京。他说他会寄给O一张你、你妻子和你女儿的照片。他称她为O的妹妹。
He also said you were a lot like him, a wanderer, a bit of a loner, and that you often went off by yourself for stretches of time and didn't talk about it much. But he sounded very proud of you. Very protective. As though he was worried I'd slag you to bits or something.
他还说你很像他，是个漫游者，有点独来独往，经常独自离开一段时间，不怎么谈论它。但他听起来为你感到非常骄傲。非常有保护欲。就好像他担心我会把你贬得一文不值什么的。
And of course, I wouldn't do that. Like O. says, what's the point?
当然，我不会那样做。就像O说的，有什么意义呢？
You're lucky, Mike, to have a father standing up for you. Have you introduced your famous penny wieners to the Japanese? Sayonara, X.
你很幸运，迈克，有一个为你挺身而出的父亲。你把你的成名作热狗介绍给日本人了吗？再见，X。
Since posting those letters on the internet, X. has identified herself as Miriam Toews. She has a book coming out in the fall in the United States called Swing Low, A Life. Her letters were read for us by Alexa Junge. Read X.'s other letters at openletters.net.
自将这些信件贴在互联网上后，X已确认自己就是米里亚姆·托伊斯。她秋天在美国有一本新书要出版，叫《下摆，生活》。她的信是由亚历克莎·琼格为我们朗读的。请在openletters.net阅读X的其他信件。
Coming up, suburban child wants unhappy childhood. Adopting couple tries to reunite biological mom and baby. What is this country coming to? In a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，郊区孩子想要不幸的童年。收养夫妇试图让亲生母亲和婴儿团聚。这个国家到底怎么了？国际公共广播电台节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today, Stories from the Missing Parents Bureau. We have arrived at case three.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的各种不同故事。今天，来自“失踪父母调查局”的故事。我们来到了第三个案例。
Case Three, I'm an Orphan; Don't Tell My Mom. This is a story about wanting parents to be gone from the scene. It begins in the 1980s when Starlee Kine, who was 11 years old, decided, among other things, that she wanted to be a child star. With her parents' generous help, she attended a series of classes run by a man named Kevin McDermott. Kevin was regarded as one of the best child acting coaches in the business. Starlee picks up the story.
案例三，我是孤儿，别告诉妈妈。这是一个关于想要父母消失的故事。它开始于20世纪80年代，当时11岁的斯塔莉·凯恩决定，除其他外，她想成为童星。在父母慷慨的帮助下，她参加了由一个叫凯文·麦克德莫特的人开设的一系列课程。凯文被认为是业内最好的童星教练之一。斯塔莉开始讲这个故事。
By far, the strangest acting exercise I've ever heard of or participated in is one we did in his class called character group therapy. We were instructed to make up a character, the only guideline being that they had to be troubled in some way. We were given six weeks to develop. At the end of which, an actual certified psychologist came into the class and psychoanalyzed our characters during a group therapy session.
到目前为止，我听说过或参与过的最奇怪的表演练习是我们班上一个叫“角色团体治疗”的练习。我们被指示编造一个角色，唯一的准则就是他们必须在某种程度上遇到麻烦。我们有六周的时间来发展这个角色。六周结束时，一位真正的专业心理学家走进班级，在小组治疗会议期间对我们的角色进行心理分析。
I chose to be an orphan. My character had been abandoned by her parents as a little child. I don't remember her name, but it was something androgynous, like Sam. I'd lived on the street briefly, but for the most part I'd been tossed from one foster home to another. I was terribly suspicious of adults. There was a family that wanted to adopt me and I secretly hoped they would, but was too tough to admit it. The only one I truly trusted was my dog, who I'd found in a gutter or something when he was just a puppy.
我选择做一个孤儿。我的角色在小时候被父母遗弃了。我不记得她的名字，但它有点中性，像萨姆。我曾短暂地流落街头，但大部分时间是被从一个寄养家庭扔到另一个。我对成年人极其怀疑。有个家庭想领养我，我暗暗希望他们这么做，但又太坚强不愿承认。我唯一真正信任的是我的狗，它是我在他还是幼犬时在阴沟里或其他什么地方捡到的。
To the best of my memory, nearly all my fellow classmates picked orphans as well. They had similar back stories filled with uncannily familiar details. I tracked some of these people down, but they remember even less than I do. Probably because afterwards they actually went on to play these characters professionally. All of my classmates were working actors in some capacity or other. You'd see them as you flipped through the channels, playing comatose children on St. Elsewhere , or Ricky Schroder's first kiss on Silver Spoons . Or the young version of an older, more established actor on a sitcom special flashback episode.
据我的记忆，我几乎所有的同学也都选择了孤儿。他们有类似的背景故事，充满了令人毛骨悚然的熟悉细节。我追踪了这些人中的一些，但他们记得的甚至比我还少。可能是因为事后他们真的去职业扮演这些角色了。我所有的同学都是某种意义上的职业演员。你会看到他们在电视转台时，扮演《圣伊丽莎白》中昏迷的孩子，或者是《银汤匙》中瑞奇·施罗德的初吻对象。或者是情景喜剧特别回忆剧集中老年、更有名的演员的年轻版本。
In my entire aspiring career, I didn't land a single role. No commercials, no pilots, no features. Nothing. It's the kind of record that sticks with a person, permanently labeling them, like alcoholism. I will forever be a failed child star.
在我整个有抱负的生涯中，我没接到一个角色。没有广告，没有试播集，没有电影。什么都没有。这是一种会跟随人一生的记录，永久性地给他们贴上标签，像酗酒一样。我永远是个失败的童星。
Kevin still teaches, his reputation as solid as ever. And I visited his current class to see if they were still pretending to be orphans.
凯文依然在教学，他的名声依然稳固。我参观了他的现任班级，看看他们是否还在假装自己是孤儿。
OK, Grady, let us see an expression that shows teeth and mouth open.
好的，格雷迪，让我们看一个露出牙齿且嘴巴张开的表情。
The class is in a different location from when I was a student, but some things are the same-- the metal folding chairs, the special spotlight that Kevin uses to cue scenes. The walls in the waiting room are still plastered with children's head shots, including an autographed photo of Marc Price. Marc Price played the neighbor Skippy on Family Ties. He was in love with Mallory. The picture was up when I was in the class and it was always a source of pride to me, that Skippy and I had the same acting teacher.
班级位置和我做学生时不同，但有些东西是一样的——金属折叠椅，凯文用来提示场景的特殊聚光灯。候诊室的墙上依然贴满了童星头像，包括一张马克·普莱斯的签名照。马克·普莱斯在《凡人琐事》里扮演邻居斯基皮。他爱着马洛里。那张照片我在班里时就在那里，能和斯基皮拥有同一个表演老师一直是我引以为豪的事。
Mid series, a back story was added to Skippy's character. Skippy discovered he was adopted as a baby. I point the picture out to the class and they smile politely. It turns out they've never heard of Family Ties.
系列剧中期，斯基皮的角色被添加了一个背景故事。斯基皮发现他是个婴儿时被收养的。我指着照片对班上同学说，他们礼貌地微笑着。原来他们从来没听说过《凡人琐事》。
Kevin still does character group therapy, but now he plays the therapist himself. It begins the same way it always has. The kids sit in a circle, they do a muscle relaxation exercise, and then Kevin counts them down into it, like he's hypnotizing them.
凯文依然做角色团体治疗，但现在他自己扮演治疗师。它以一贯的方式开始。孩子们围坐成一圈，做肌肉放松练习，然后凯文倒数让他们进入状态，就像他在催眠他们一样。
Three, you're in the peer group counseling session. Two, you are this character. One, welcome. Some of you are new. Some of you started last week in our first group. I'm Dr. Roberts, for those of you who are new tonight. And I'd like to go around the room and I'd like everyone to tell us their first name and anything about themselves, or why they're here, that they would like to share.
三，你在同伴咨询会议中。二，你是这个角色。一，欢迎。你们中有些人是新来的。有些人上周参加了我们第一组。我是罗伯茨博士，为今晚新来的同学介绍一下。我想绕着房间转一圈，让每个人告诉我们他们的名字，以及任何关于他们自己，或者为什么他们在这里，他们想分享的内容。
There's a stunning absence of orphans. In their place is a potpourri of trendy WB-style back stories and scandalous hour-long drama side plots.
孤儿惊人地缺席了。取而代之的是各种流行WB风格的背景故事和可耻的一小时戏剧侧线情节。
One boy impregnated his high school girlfriend and is full of despair over the possibility of her getting an abortion. There's a girl in an abusive relationship. Another boy cuts up his arms after his father becomes an alcoholic. One of the characters saw her boyfriend get killed in a drive-by shooting, an idea the actress got from an audition for The Practice she'd gone on right before class. The only kid whose back story is remotely orphan-like is played by a boy named Robert [? Negron. ?]
一个男孩让他的高中女友怀孕了，对她可能堕胎充满绝望。有一个女孩处于虐待关系中。另一个男孩在父亲变成酒鬼后割自己的胳膊。其中一个角色看到男友在驾车枪击中被杀，这个灵感来自这位女演员在下课前去参加的《律师本色》试镜。背景故事最接近孤儿的一个孩子是由一个叫罗伯特·内格隆的男孩扮演的。
He doesn't cry. He doesn't even like talking about his feelings. He could care less about the other kids' problems.
他不哭。他甚至不喜欢谈论自己的感受。他根本不在乎其他孩子的问题。
I'm kind of over it to tell you the truth.
说实话，我有点厌倦了。
OK.
好的。
If my car breaks down, I don't form a club with other people whose cars are broken down. I go to someone whose car is running, for god's sakes. Jesus.
如果我的车坏了，我不会和其他车坏了的人组个俱乐部。看在上帝份上，我会找个车能跑的人。天哪。
These kids don't understand what being a real fake orphan is all about. Back in the day, orphans were strictly of the Punky Brewster, Webster variety-- sincere, saccharine, cloying.
这些孩子不明白什么是真正的假孤儿。在过去，孤儿严格来说是《庞奇·布鲁斯特》或《韦伯斯特》风格的——真诚、肉麻、矫情。
In my class, just as one kid finished sobbing his eyes out, another would start, and rightly so. Now there seems to be a trend of more realistic, less damp performances. In places of sap, the kids seem to challenge their depression into snappy, teenage angst, opting to come across deep instead of sniveling.
在我班上，正如一个孩子哭得眼泪汪汪，另一个会开始哭，而且理应如此。现在似乎有一种更现实、没那么潮湿表演的趋势。在矫情的地方，孩子们似乎把他们的抑郁转化为急促的、青少年的焦虑，选择表现得深沉而不是抽泣。
Name.
名字。
I'm Jeremy.
我是杰里米。
Jeremy, what makes you feel sadness in your life?
杰里米，什么让你在生活中感到悲伤？
Sadness. Sadness usually comes from waking up in the morning.
悲伤。悲伤通常来自早上醒来。
Why is that a sad time?
为什么那是悲伤的时间？
I don't know. I guess the show goes on.
不知道。我猜演出还得继续。
What show goes on?
什么演出继续？
You know, the show. The show we have to show people.
你知道，那个演出。我们必须表演给别人看的演出。
By the end of the class it was clear. We all chose to be orphans because at the time, they were the norm, the given. Arnold, Willis, Fonzie, Ponyboy, Annie-- orphans dominated both the big and small screen. They were even recruited to breathe new life into the classics. When a show's ratings would drop, one of two things most likely happened. A baby was born or an orphan was discovered sleeping in the hall or shoplifting from the store. Soon after, the orphan became a permanent member of the cast. We picked orphans in response to market pressures, just like Kevin's students today.
到班级结束时，这很清楚了。我们当时选择成为孤儿是因为那时他们是常态，是默认设定。阿诺德、威利斯、冯兹、小马哥、安妮——孤儿统治了大银幕和小荧幕。他们甚至被招募来为经典剧集注入活力。当剧集收视率下降时，最可能发生两件事之一。一个婴儿出生了，或者一个孤儿被发现在大厅睡觉或在商店行窃。不久后，这个孤儿就成了常驻角色。我们选择孤儿是对市场压力的回应，就像今天凯文的学生一样。
Name?
名字？
Johnny.
强尼。
Last name?
姓氏？
Calzone.
卡尔佐内。
Age?
年龄？
Want me to spell it for you?
想让我帮你拼出来吗？
No, that's OK. You seem to have kind of an attitude, Johnny.
不，没事。你似乎有点态度，强尼。
Yeah?
是吗？
Yeah.
是。
That was Scott [? Newson. ?] He tells me he's been watching a lot of The Sopranos lately. But he says the name Johnny Calzone just popped into his head.
那是斯科特·纽森。他告诉我他最近看了很多《黑道家族》。但他说是名字强尼·卡尔佐内突然出现在他脑海里的。
Tell us a little bit about why you're here.
告诉我们一点为什么你在这里。
Because I [BLEEP] love your group.
因为我[消音]喜欢你的小组。
Having said all that, I do think there's a personal element to choosing these characters. For the most part, these kids are from upper-middle-class families that are pretty supportive. Playing these parts, they aren't rebelling against their families as much as fantasizing about what life is like on the other side.
说了这么多，我确实认为选择这些角色有一个个人因素。在很大程度上，这些孩子来自相当支持他们的中上层家庭。扮演这些角色，他们与其说是在反抗家庭，不如说是在幻想另一边的生活是什么样子的。
In my case, I chose to be an orphan partly because I came from the kind of home where if my sister and I wanted to visit our friends who live directly across the street, instead of letting us just walk across, my mom would put us in the car, back the car out of our driveway across a deserted, residential street, and up into their driveway to eliminate all chance of us getting killed in a hit and run.
就我而言，我选择做一个孤儿部分是因为我来自这样一个家庭，如果我和我妹妹想去拜访住在街道对面的朋友，我妈妈不会让我们直接走过去，而是会把我们放进车里，把车从车道倒出，穿过一条荒无人烟的住宅街道，倒进他们的车道，以消除我们被车撞死的任何机会。
The orphan's life, though was all about freedom. Orphans didn't have to answer to anyone. Didn't have a well-intentioned but irrational adult in charge of their every move. They had their smarts, they had their sidekick pet, they had their broken locket, and they had themselves. That was it.
然而，孤儿的生活完全是关于自由的。孤儿不需要对任何人负责。没有一个出发点很好但不理智的成年人掌管他们的一举一动。他们有自己的聪明才智，他们有自己的跟班宠物，他们有破旧的小挂坠盒，他们有他们自己。就是这样。
During my years in Kevin's class, a rope ladder made of tied-together bed sheets permanently hung from my suburban ranch house's second-story window for when I would have to sneak out in the middle of the night in search of my real parents. That was my favorite game.
在凯文班级的那些年里，我郊区牧场式房子的二楼窗户上永久悬挂着一架用床单绑成的绳梯，那是为了我需要在深夜溜出去寻找亲生父母时用的。那是由于我最喜欢的游戏。
Character group therapy was just as good. Being in Kevin's class, it sometimes wasn't clear whether I was aspiring to be a child star orphan or an actual orphan.
角色团体治疗也一样好。在凯文的班里，有时不清楚我是在渴望成为一个童星孤儿还是一个真正的孤儿。
Starlee Kine is one of the producers of our program.
斯塔莉·凯恩是我们节目的制片人之一。
Case Four, Runaway Mom.
案例四，逃跑的妈妈。
Three years ago, Dan Savage and his boyfriend, Terry, adopted a baby. It was an open adoption, the kind where the birth parents choose the adoptive parents, and then stay in touch after handing over the child. But things have not been working out according to plan.
三年前，丹·萨维奇和他的男友泰瑞收养了一个婴儿。那是一次开放式收养，即亲生父母选择养父母，并在交出孩子后保持联系。但事情并没有按计划进行。
We decided to go ahead and try for an open adoption because we wanted our kid's biological parents to be a part of his life. We did this even though our agency warned us that we might be in for a long wait. The birth mothers who spoke at a two-day seminar we attended both said that finding good Christian homes for their babies was their first concern. Birth control wasn't a concern for them, apparently.
我们决定尝试进行开放式收养，因为我们希望孩子亲生父母能成为他生命的一部分。尽管我们机构警告我们可能需要漫长的等待，我们还是这么做了。我们参加的两天研讨会上发言的两位亲生母亲都说，为她们的宝宝找到好的基督教家庭是她们的首要考虑。显然避孕并不是她们的考虑。
As it turns out, we didn't have to wait long for a birth mother to come along who believed being born once was enough. A few weeks after our paperwork was done, we got a call from the agency. A 19-year-old street kid named Melissa, homeless by choice and seven months pregnant by accident, had selected my boyfriend and I from our adoption agency's pool of pre-screened parent wannabes. The day we met Melissa, the agency suggested that all three of us go out for lunch to get to know each other. We were bursting with touchy-feely questions, which we soon realized was a problem.
事实证明，我们没等多久就有一位认为生一次孩子就足够了的亲生母亲出现了。我们的文书工作完成后几周，我们接到了机构的电话。一个名叫梅丽莎的19岁街头少年，选择流浪且意外怀孕七个月，从我们的收养机构筛选出的候补父母库中选中了我和我男友。我们见到梅丽莎的那天，机构建议我们三个人一起出去吃午餐互相了解一下。我们充满了感性十足的问题，很快意识到这是个问题。
Stoic and wary, Melissa was only interested in the facts. She was pregnant. She couldn't have a baby on the streets. And so she was doing an adoption.
坚忍且警惕的梅丽莎只对事实感兴趣。她怀孕了。她没法在街头抚养孩子。所以她决定收养。
We were with Melissa when DJ was born and we were in her hospital room two days later when it was time for her to give him up.
DJ出生时我们就在现场，两天后当她要把他交出来时，我们也在她的病房里。
Before we could take DJ home, we had to take him out of his mother's arms as she sat sobbing in her bed. It was the hardest thing I've ever done in my life. I was 33 years old when we adopted DJ and I thought I knew what a broken heart was. I thought mine had been broken a couple of times. I thought I knew how a broken heart felt and what it looked like. I didn't know anything.
在我们带DJ回家之前，我们必须把他从坐在床上啜泣的母亲怀里抱走。那是我一生中做过的最艰难的事情。我们收养DJ时我33岁，我以为我了解什么是心碎。我以为我的心曾被伤过几次。我以为我知道心碎的感觉和样子。我什么都不知道。
You know what a broken heart looks like? Like a sobbing teenager in a hospital bed giving a two-day-old infant she knows she can't take care of to a couple she hopes can. There was nothing remotely uplifting about the moment. She didn't smile bravely through her tears and say, take good care of my baby. She folded up and sobbed and we stood there, feeling like monsters.
你知道心碎是什么样子的吗？就像一个啜泣的青少年在病床上，把自己明知无法照顾的出生两天的婴儿交给一对她希望可以照顾好的夫妇。那一刻没有丝毫令人振奋的地方。她没能在泪水中勇敢微笑说，请好好照顾我的宝宝。她崩溃啜泣，我们站在那里，感觉像怪物。
We didn't meet Bacchus, our son's birth father, until almost a year after we'd adopted DJ. He was homeless, too, and Bacchus was his street name. Melissa hooked up with him for a few weeks one summer and by the time she realized she was pregnant, the God of Wine was gone.
我们在收养DJ几乎一年后才见到巴克斯，我们儿子的亲生父亲。他也是流浪者，巴克斯是他的街头名字。梅丽莎那个夏天和他在一起了几周，当她意识到怀孕时，这位酒神已经离开了。
When we adopted DJ, Bacchus didn't know he was a father, or that his son had been adopted by a gay couple. So we were tense when Bacchus surfaced in New Orleans shortly before DJ's first birthday. But all Bacchus wanted was what Melissa was getting-- pictures, regular visits, phone calls. Bacchus turned out to be Melissa's opposite, smiling easily and quick to laugh.
我们收养DJ时，巴克斯不知道他是父亲，也不知道他的儿子被一对同性恋伴侣收养了。所以在DJ一周岁生日前夕，当巴克斯在纽奥良出现时，我们很紧张。但巴克斯想要的只是梅丽莎得到的——照片、定期访问、电话。巴克斯原来是梅丽莎的对立面，总是面带微笑，爱笑。
Like most homeless street kids, Melissa works a circuit-- Portland and Seattle in the spring and early summer, Denver, Minneapolis, Chicago, and New York in the late summer, early fall, New Orleans, Phoenix, Las Vegas in the winter. Then it's back up to Portland.
像大多数流浪的街头少年一样，梅丽莎有一条路线——春季和初夏在波特兰和西雅图，夏末初秋在丹佛、明尼阿波利斯、芝加哥和纽约，冬季在纽奥良、凤凰城、拉斯维加斯。然后回到波特兰。
When Melissa's in Seattle during the summer we all get together in a park where she hangs out with her friends, so that she can visit with DJ and show him off. She keeps in touch by phone the rest of the year, but her calls are usually pretty short. She asks how we're doing. We ask how she's doing. Then we put DJ on the phone.
当梅丽莎夏天在西雅图时，我们都会在公园集合，她和朋友们在一起，这样她可以看望DJ并炫耀他。其余时间她通过电话联系，但她的电话通常很短。她问我们怎么样。我们问她怎么样。然后我们把DJ放上电话。
The last time Melissa called, she didn't ask for DJ. Her boyfriend, she told me, died the night before of alcohol poisoning. They were sleeping on a sidewalk, he was lying beside her, and when she woke up, he was dead.
上次梅丽莎打电话时，她没问起DJ。她告诉我，她的男友前一天晚上因酒精中毒死了。他们睡在人行道上，他躺在她身边，当她醒来时，他已经死了。
That call came in early November and we haven't heard from Melissa since. Three months ago, I started calling hospitals, then morgues. When the clerk at the county morgue in New Orleans asked me to describe Melissa, without thinking, I started to say, well, she's kind of quiet. The morgue attendant laughed and told me that all his Jane Does fit that description.
那通电话是在11月初打来的，从那以后我们再没听到梅丽莎的消息。三个月前，我开始给医院打电话，然后是停尸房。当纽奥良县停尸房的职员让我描述梅丽莎时，我没过脑子，刚开始说，嗯，她有点安静。停尸房工作人员笑了，告诉我他那所有的无名女尸都符合那个描述。
Then just as suddenly, Bacchus stopped calling. Soon, Bacchus's stepmother, who would be DJ's biological step-grandmother, was calling us, too, asking if we knew where Bacchus was. He drifted from New Orleans to Vermont to Texas, she told us, and then disappeared.
然后突然间，巴克斯也不打电话了。很快，巴克斯的继母，也就是DJ的亲生继祖母，也打电话给我们，问我们知不知道巴克斯在哪。她告诉我们，他从纽奥良漂泊到佛蒙特到德克萨斯，然后就消失了。
We haven't heard from Melissa for six months. Bacchus has been missing for four months now. DJ's birthday came and went, and nothing. No calls.
我们已经六个月没听到梅丽莎的消息了。巴克斯也失踪四个月了。DJ的生日也过了，什么都没有。没电话。
Last Sunday I was tearing down the wallpaper in my office at home when DJ walked in. His best friend, a little boy named Haven, had spent the night. After Haven's mother picked him up, DJ dragged a stool into my office and sat down to watch me pull wallpaper down in long strips.
上周我正在家里办公室撕壁纸，DJ走了进来。他最好的朋友，一个叫黑文的小男孩，在那过了一夜。黑文的妈妈接走他后，DJ拖了张凳子进我办公室坐下，看着我把壁纸撕成一条条。
"Have has a mommy," DJ suddenly said. "And I have a mommy." DJ's going through this thing where he likes to make statements of fact and have us confirm them for him. It's as if he's testing himself, making sure his reality jives with ours.
“黑文有妈妈，”DJ突然说。“我也有妈妈。”DJ正经历一个阶段，他喜欢做事实陈述，让我们为他确认。就好像他在测试自己，确保他的现实与我们的相符。
"That's right," I responded. "You have a money too, just like Haven."
“没错，”我回应道。“你也有妈妈，就像黑文一样。”
He went on. "My mommy's name is Melissa. I came out of Melissa's tummy. I play with my mommy in the park."
他继续说。“我妈妈叫梅丽莎。我是从梅丽莎肚子里出来的。我和我妈妈在公园玩。”
Then DJ looked at me and asked a question. "When will I see my mommy again?"
然后DJ看着我问了一个问题。“我什么时候能再见到妈妈？”
"This summer," I said, hoping it wasn't a lie. "We'll see Melissa in the park this summer, just like last summer."
“今年夏天，”我说，希望这不是个谎言。“我们今年夏天会在公园见到梅丽莎，就像去年夏天一样。”
I'm not sure what we'll tell DJ if Melissa really has disappeared forever. What if he asks why his mother didn't love him enough to stick around for him? Maybe we'll tell him that some people self-destruct, and maybe Melissa knew she was going to self-destruct and loved him so much that she wanted to make sure he was someplace he wouldn't get hurt. And maybe this answer will be good enough for DJ. And maybe it won't.
我不确定如果梅丽莎真的永远消失了，我们会告诉DJ什么。如果他问为什么他妈妈没爱他到留下来照顾他怎么办？也许我们会告诉他，有些人会自我毁灭，也许梅丽莎知道她会自我毁灭，而且非常爱他，所以她想确保他在一个不会受伤害的地方。也许这个答案对DJ来说足够好。也许不够。
One of the things my boyfriend brought to our relationship was a video camera. I didn't let him bring it to the hospital with us that day, though. I didn't want a video camera in the room. I wanted to experience those moments, DJ's first moments, in real time, not sitting in front of a TV months later. Maybe I was being selfish.
我男友带进我们关系的东西之一是一台摄像机。那天我不让他带进医院。我不想要一台摄像机在房间里。我想实时体验那些时刻，DJ的第一时刻，而不是几个月后坐在电视前。也许我很自私。
If Melissa has disappeared forever, well, I deeply regret that we don't have any videotape of DJ with his mother. If he could see her the way we saw her, holding him, feeding him, softly singing to him in her hospital bed the night he was born, he would know what I know, that his mother loved him very much.
如果梅丽莎真的永远消失了，那么，我深感遗憾的是我们没有DJ和他母亲的任何录像。如果他能像我们看到的那样看到她，抱着他，喂他，在他出生那晚在病床上轻声为他唱歌，他就会知道我所知道的，他的母亲非常爱他。
Dan Savage is the author of The Kid: (What Happened After My Boyfriend and I Decided to Go Get Pregnant).
丹·萨维奇是《孩子：我和男友决定去怀孕后发生了什么》的作者。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Alix Spiegel's story was produced with funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting. The rap song after her story was written by Travolta W. and performed by him, Kevin G. and Keith L. They are juvenile offenders at Chicago's Audi Home Detention Center as part of a show put on behind bars by Chicago's Music Theatre Workshop.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔的故事制作经费由公共广播公司资助。她故事后的说唱歌曲由特拉沃尔塔·W创作，由他和凯文·G以及基思·L表演。他们是芝加哥奥迪家庭拘留中心的少年犯，作为芝加哥音乐剧场工作室在狱中上演的节目的一部分。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Torey Malatia. He'd prefer it if our show instructed people how to--
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。如果我们的节目指导人们如何……他会更喜欢。
Help transform the moon for human habitation and create some kind of food supply that will replace meat.
帮助改造月球以供人类居住，并创造出一种能替代肉类的食物来源。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台，PRI。